hello people my name is ty in my channel
is like Ava's mom and I'm going to share
with you the movies that I want to watch
before the end of 2015 Justin Morgan
here from the new feature builder
channel and this 2015 I'm looking
forward to watching a number of movies
it was a la semana roof from YouTube
channel out of school TV what's up
everyone it's chris with c3 pier and i
have got to say that the movie i am most
excited for for the end of 2015 would
have to be Star Wars 2015 is almost over
and it's about 2 GB 2,000 votes would
you be it's about to be 2016 and I have
not watched hardly anything because I'm
a mom of three kids and only thing that
I get to watch is the kids channel part
on netflix but so the first thing that I
think I want to see which I'm going to
try to see Lord I'm backing out of it
already the first thing that I'm going
to see his train wreck that look really
funny I mean and Amy Schumer is
hilarious to me so train wreck looks
right on my Ally cos you know and the
movie I'm excited to see is concussion
starring will smith if you don't know
it's a story about a foreign doctor who
comes to the US and discovers that
football is causing a few players to get
concussions and it's pretty our favorite
line from the trail so far tell the
cheap concussion is set to come out
around christmas time of course star
wars can't be left off the list I love
the universe i'm looking forward to how
they carry forward the the art this
story this universe and see what they do
with it hopefully they knock it out of
the park I'm not like the biggest star
wars fan by any means I don't have any
star wars video games attire action
figures but i do like Star Wars and I've
seen him a handful of times it's just
something I kind of grew up with seeing
every now and again so I'm excited for
it I think everyone is kind of hyped for
it we're all a little bit cautious as
well I think you should be cautious just
you know don't set your hopes up like
way too high so they get disappointed I
think it's going to be good though
unfortunately i'm not even going to be
able to go to the midnight
going talk about a first-world problem
but I'm going to be in disneyland on
December eighteenth so but maybe now
that Disneyland are not Disneyland but
Disney owns Star Wars maybe Disneyland
is gonna be all decked out in Star Wars
stuff on that day I don't know that will
be actually kind of interesting to see
if anything happens with that but i'll
be going later on at some point the rest
of my life my wife's family they're all
going to the midnight showing so we will
have to catch up on that at some point
afterwards looking forward to seeing the
Martian still haven't seen it saw the
reviews I loved it I loved the concept
that something different it's not the
same exact movie and so I'm looking
forward to seeing that I like sci-fi
like science at least watching it and so
I'm interested in seeing it Hunger Games
got to see The Hunger Games got to see
that series i'm behind so I some
catching up to do I can't wait to see
that that series finish off and you know
first I fell over the first movie so I
can't finish can't wait to finish the
rest of them I know y'all gonna fight me
okay like I said I have kids I'm gonna
say the hundred times I haven't seen
Jurassic world I have not seen Jurassic
world because my kids would probably
crap yourselves so one day when their
sleep I'm gonna watch Jurassic world
because i heard it was fabulous no
spoilers but definitely make sure that
you comment below and tell me if you
guys saw Jurassic world and is it worth
to be on this list in terms of TV shows
TV shows I'm waiting for I'm a CW guy so
I need to catch up and finish up on
supernatural the arrow the flash and
that that's mainly it supernatural the
arrow the flash those are the main shows
haven't seen the flash yet so I'm
excited to catch up and binge on that at
some point supernatural I'm catching up
on now loving it loving the brothers i
love the action they're still keeping
things going somehow in the arrow i fell
in love with that series they did it
right and they continue to do it right
the last season i watch was intense so i
can't wait to see the next one that's
not it looks like it's going to be
really really good so i'm going to get
into that before the end of 2015 and
also master of none it looks like that
dry
humor that I'm really into so I'm
excited to watch that and I'm going to
watch these things I'm telling you and
I'm telling myself that too before 2016
I'm gonna watch these shows and I'm
going to give a verdict on if they're
good or not and what last movie I can't
wait to see is creed saw the reviews saw
the reviews I'm impressed so far I'm
impressed I want to see Sylvester back
on the back on screen mr. Jordan did
well on his role I'm glad there's a mix
of action there's a great mix of
character development and story and I
hear that they did a great job of
setting up themselves separate from the
past movies yet making you feel
nostalgic about the other ones so I'm
excited to see those movies those shows
my name is Justin Morgan of the new
future builder channel check me out here
on youtube and check me out at new
future builder calm and that is all I
have and as usual treat each day as a
building block to a better future peace
that's all the time I have for today
guys my name is Omar Abreu from youtube
channel out of school TV o UT o FSK ool
TV I'm see you next time oh oh again my
name is Chris my channel name is C
threep which the name I kind of got from
c-3po so maybe I am more of a Star Wars
fan then I realized the best place you
can find me is on YouTube that's why I
do my thing I post simplified tutorials
about music mixing and recording so yeah
youtube.com slash C 3 and that's it
right so if you want to see what the
verdict is make sure that you head over
to my channel if you're not subscribed I
am once again lavas mom on YouTube and
you can find me on youtube instagram
twitter everywhere facebook it's all I
Ava's mom can't wait to talk to you guys
again bye
you